donc épique dit
ici qu'Apple Apple
prend indistinctement 30%
de tous les achats intégrés à l'application
que vous effectuez lorsque vous êtes sur Fortnite ou
que vous
utilisez une autre application et Epic veut
proposer une boutique d'applications concurrente
et au cœur de cette question  est de
savoir si Apple peut ou non limiter la
concurrence
à son magasin d'applications si Apple peut dire que
nous allons être le seul magasin d'applications,
nous allons être le seul
contrôle de qualité sur les applications qui
arrivent
et vous devez toujours nous payer  certaines
taxes afin d'obtenir vos applications ou d'obtenir vos
paiements
via ios, donc l'antitrust est l'un des
principaux moyens d'aborder le
pouvoir de monopole et je pense que ce que nous
voyons, c'est beaucoup de très grandes
entreprises
dont les gens sont de plus en plus
sceptiques et ils '  je suis sceptique quant à
l'accumulation de pouvoir dans un petit groupe
de mains d'entreprises,
ils sont sceptiques quant au pouvoir d'apple du pouvoir de
google du pouvoir de facebook du
pouvoir d'amazon et c'est pourquoi l'
antitrust qui a été l'un des
outils tha  t nous utilisons pour faire face à
ce type de concentration ce genre de
pouvoir de monopole si c'est si gros
c'est pourquoi nous constatons un regain d'
intérêt pour l'antitrust je pense que
si apple perd ce procès vous
en verrez probablement plus
vous en verrez probablement  plus d'application anti-trust
dans l'écosystème
parce que l'antitrust est traditionnellement
parce que les régulateurs antitrust ont
traditionnellement autorisé ce type d'
intégration verticale, de
nombreuses entreprises ont suivi cette voie
google facebook
et il y a donc une chance que d'autres le
fassent, il y a donc une chance que les régulateurs
s'en prennent  d'autres entreprises également une fois que
nous voyons ce qui se passe ici,
je pense qu'epic a un bon argument selon lequel
les politiques d'apple sont exclusives
et qu'elles sont anticoncurrentielles et donc
vous savez uniquement sur la base de ce que j'ai vu jusqu'à
présent,
je pense que je pense que epic a un  bon cas